[Music]
so there's a lot of discussion of what
might life look like on other planets if
life has evolved there will diversify in
a way like the world today and there's a
lot of speculation about that question
but we actually don't need to go to
other planets to ask that question and
that's because there are different
places on earth that have had different
evolutionary histories and so we can ask
on different places in the world has
life evolved in the same way under
similar conditions and it turns out that
we're very well set for that because
there are isolated islands that have
been their own evolutionary theaters if
you will that life has evolved very
independently for a long time the best
example of that I think is New Zealand
now New Zealand broke off from Australia
about 80 million years ago and this was
before moderate most modern mammal
groups had really diversified and in
fact today there are no native land
mammals on New Zealand there are some
seals that come ashore on the beach
there are few species of bats but there
are no rodents there are no carnivores
and so on except the ones that humans
have introduced in the last couple
hundred years so the question is how did
New Zealand evolve in the absence of
land mammals well it turns out that
birds in particular have taken advantage
of that and they've evolved to do many
of the things that mammals do elsewhere
in the world and there are carnivores
and herbivores and all kinds of birds
now if we thought that evolution is
deterministic then we would expect New
Zealand even though it's dominated by
birds to have species very similar to
those elsewhere in the world but that's
not at all the case the best example is
the Kiwi now people know Kiwi it's a
bird this big it turns out that it has
no wings it runs around on the ground it
has an extremely good sense of smell
which is very unusual for birds it also
has little whiskers very similar to
mammals basically a Kiwi does the same
thing that a Hedgehog or maybe a badger
or an armadillo does it goes around
rooting through the leaf litter looking
for worms and other invertebrates yet it
is adapted in a very different way and
in fact the entire cast of characters in
New Zealand is very different there are
carnivorous parrots
there
are parrots that are completely
flightless and walk around on the ground
looking for seeds there's a 10 foot tall
MOA a bird that a land bird that can't
fly that is the dominant herbivore that
looks nothing like a deer or a bison or
its ecological equivalents elsewhere so
New Zealand is an alternative world if
you will almost an alternative planet in
evolutionary terms and what has evolved
there is completely different from the
rest of the world and this is true of
other places Australia in at least some
risk that respects is very different
Madagascar or go back to the age of the
dinosaurs
well the dinosaurs came they went
extinct if evolution is so deterministic
why don't we have t-rex and brontosaurus
type dinosaurs today it's because
evolution has gone in a very different
different direction so we don't need to
go to other planets to see how
deterministic evolution is we can just
look in different places on earth and we
can see that the outcome often is very
different
[Music]
you